what started as a platform for hobbyists
is poised to become a multi-billion
dollar industry inspection environmental
monitoring photography and film and
journalism these are some of the
potential applications for commercial
drones and their enablers are the
capabilities being developed at research
facilities around the world for example
before aerial package-delivery entered
our social consciousness an autonomous
fleet of flying machines built a six
meter tall tower composed of 1,500
bricks in front of a live audience of
the frack centre in France and several
years ago they started to fly with ropes
by tethering fly machines they can
achieve high speeds and accelerations in
very tight spaces
they can also autonomously build 10 cell
structures skills learn include how to
carry loads how to cope with
disturbances and in general how to
interact with the physical world today
we want to show you some new projects
that we've been working on their aim is
to push the boundary of what can be
achieved with autonomous flight now for
a system to function autonomously it
must collectively know the location of
its mobile objects in space back at our
lab at ETH Zurich we often use external
cameras to locate objects which then
allows us to focus our efforts on the
rapid development of highly dynamic
tasks for the demos you will see today
however we will use new localization
technology developed by various Studios
a spinoff from our lab there are no
external cameras each flying machine
uses onboard sensors to determine its
location in space in onboard computation
to determine what its actions should be
the only external commands are
high-level ones such as
takeoff and land
this is a so-called tail sitter it's an
aircraft - tries to have its cake and
eat it like other fixed-wing aircraft it
is efficient and forward flight much
more so than helicopters and variations
thereof unlike most other fixed-wing
aircraft however it is capable of
hovering which has huge advantages for
takeoff landing and general versatility
there is no free lunch unfortunately one
of the limitations with tail sitters is
they're susceptible to disturbances such
as wind gusts we're developing new
control architectures and algorithms
that address this limitation
the ideas for the aircraft to recover no
matter what state it finds itself in and
through practice improve its performance
over time
when doing research we often ask
ourselves fundamental abstract questions
that try to get at the heart of the
matter for example one such question
would be what is the minimum number of
moving parts needed for controlled
flight now there are practical reasons
why you may want to know the answer to
such a question helicopters for example
are affectionately known as machines
with a thousand moving parts all
conspiring to do you bodily arm it turns
out that decades ago skilled pilots were
able to fly remote-controlled aircraft
that had only two moving parts a
propeller and a tail rudder we recently
discovered that it could be done with
just one this is the mono spinner the
world's mechanically simplest
controllable flying machine invented
just a few months ago it has only one
moving part a propeller it has no flaps
no hinges no ailerons no other actuators
no other control surfaces just a simple
propeller even though it's mechanically
simple there's a lot going on in its
little electronic brain to allow it to
fly in a stable fashion and to move
anywhere at once in space even so it
doesn't yet have the sophisticated
algorithms of the tail sitter which
means that in order to get it to fly I
have to throw it just right and because
the probability of me throwing it just
right is very low given everybody
watching me what we're gonna do instead
to show you a video that we shot last
night
if the mono spinner is an exercise in
frugality this machine here the Omni
copter with its eight propellers is an
exercise in excess what can you do with
all the surplus the thing to notice that
is that it is highly symmetric as a
result it is ambivalent to orientation
this gives it an extraordinary
capability it can move anywhere wants in
space irrespective of how it where it is
facing and even of how it is rotating it
has its own complexities mainly having
to do with the interacting flows from it
say propellers some of this can be
modeled while the rest can be learned on
the fly let's take a look
if fly machines are going to enter part
of our daily lives they will need to
become extremely safe and reliable this
machine over here is actually two
separate two propeller flying machines
this one wants to spin clockwise the
southern wants to spin counterclockwise
when you put them together they behave
like one high-performance quadrocopter
if anything goes wrong however a motor
fails a propeller fails electronics even
a battery pack the machine can still fly
I'll be in a degraded fashion we're
going to demonstrate this to you now by
disabling one of its halves
this last demonstration is an
exploration of synthetic swarms the
large number of autonomous coordinated
entities offers a new palette for
aesthetic expression we've taken
commercially available micro quadcopters
each weighing less than a slice of bread
by the way and outfitted them with our
localization technology and custom
algorithms because each unit knows where
it is in space and is self controlled
there is really no limit to their number
hopefully these demonstrations will
motivate you to dream up new
revolutionary roles for fly machines
that ultra safe one over there for
example has aspirations to become a
flying lampshade on Broadway the reality
is that it is difficult to predict the
impact of NASA on technology and for
folks like us the real reward is the
journey and the act of creation it's a
continual reminder of how wonderful and
magical the universe we live in is that
it allows creative clever creatures to
sculpt it in such spectacular ways the
fact that this technology has such huge
commercial and economic potential is
just icing on the cake thank you